This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. The singer, Kali Simon, has suffered for most of her life from stage fright. Although she enjoys performing in front of an audience, she never knows when a surge of panic will bring her to her knees. In 1981, she set out to conquer her fear by arranging a string of concert dates at big concert halls. Midway through the tour, during the first of two shows in Pittsburgh, she felt her heart begin to race.
这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。歌手卡莉·西蒙（Kali Simon）大半生都饱受舞台恐惧症的困扰。尽管她很喜欢在观众面前表演，但她永远不知道什么时候突如其来的恐慌会让她双腿发软。1981年，她通过在大型音乐会场次中安排一系列演出，决心克服这种恐惧。在巡演进行到一半时，在匹兹堡的两场演出中的第一场进行期间，她感觉到自己的心跳开始加速。
Carly Simon told the audience what was happening. Go with it, they called to her. We'll be with you. She invited some fans to join her on the stage for support. They huddled around her, rubbing her arms and legs and telling her that they loved her. She was able to finish that show. But right before the next show, with 10,000 people waiting to see her perform, she collapsed. She cancelled the rest of the tour and stopped performing in public.
卡莉·西蒙把正在发生的事情告诉了观众。顺其自然吧，他们对她喊道。我们会陪着你的。她邀请了一些粉丝上台给她支持。他们围成一团，揉着她的胳膊和腿，告诉她他们爱她。她顺利完成了那场演出。但在下一场演出开始前夕，有1,000名观众在等着看她的表演，她崩溃了。她取消了余下的巡演，并停止了公开演出。
This week on Hidden Brain, how our fears get the better of us and how we can learn to get the better of them. Fear is a normal and healthy response to things that threaten to do us harm. But fear can also hold us back from doing the things we want to do. At Wayne State University, psychiatrist and neuroscientist Arash Javanbhakt studies the psychology of fear, how it helps us, how it hurts us, and what we can do to harness it. Arash Javanbhakt, welcome to Hidden Brain.
本周的“隐藏的大脑”将探讨恐惧如何战胜我们，以及我们如何学会战胜恐惧。恐惧是对威胁我们伤害的事物的正常且健康的反应。但恐惧也会阻碍我们去做我们想做的事情。在韦恩州立大学，精神病学家兼神经科学家阿拉什·贾凡巴赫特（Arash Javanbhakt）研究恐惧的心理学，它如何帮助我们，它如何伤害我们，以及我们能做些什么来驾驭它。阿拉什·贾凡巴赫特，欢迎来到“隐藏的大脑”。
Thanks for having me on, Shankar. Arash, I understand that you yourself have long suffered from a particular fear involving heights. What is your earliest memory of feeling afraid of heights? I remember actually one of my first encounters with serious fear, is this experience. I was a child, I first encounters with serious fear. It's this experience. I was a child, I think around 10 years old,
谢谢邀请我来，尚卡尔。阿拉什，据我了解，你自己长期以来一直饱受一种对高度的特定恐惧。你关于害怕高度的最早记忆是什么？我记得实际上我遭遇严重恐惧的第一次经历之一，就是这样的经历。我当时是个孩子，我第一次遭遇严重的恐惧。就是这段经历。我当时是个孩子，我想大概10岁左右，
and I got up this ladder to a balcony with my mom. My mom was basically overseeing building a house, and it was going from one level to another level. There was no stairs, so we used this ladder to go up there. It wasn't much of a height. It was like about two, three meters, but going up was much easier because I wasn't looking down. I was just looking up forward, so I didn't even register that it's scary. I just went up easily and cheerfully and then trying to come down, it was tough. And we went up there and did what we
我和我妈妈一起顺着这个梯子爬上了一个阳台。我妈妈当时基本上是在监督建房子，那是从一个楼层到另一个楼层。没有楼梯，所以我们用这个梯子上去。高度其实不高。大概两、三米左右，但是上去容易得多，因为我没有往下看。我只是向前向上看，所以我甚至没有意识到这很可怕。我只是轻松愉快地爬了上去，然后想下来的时候，就很难了。我们上去了，做了我们
were about to do. And then as we come down, she comes down first because she wanted to be able to watch me from below. So she comes down and then I get on the edge of the balcony, I look down and I'm terrified. And it took a while for me to overcome the shaking my knees and the feeling of terror inside my heart. And of course my mom's kind and encouraging face helped me. But yeah, that was my first encounter with this fear
准备要做的事。然后当我们下来时，她先下来，因为她想在下面看着我。所以她下来了，然后我走到阳台边缘，我往下看，吓坏了。我花了很长时间才克服颤抖的膝盖和内心深处的恐惧感。当然，我妈妈善良和鼓励的面孔帮助了我。但是，是的，这是我第一次遇到这种恐惧
and realizing that I'm afraid of heights. I mean, I remember when I was a small kid, I mean, there is a terror in actually getting the first leg off the ledge, you know, because it's sort of, you're swinging it out into the air before you can catch the first rung of the ladder. And it is, I mean, it is scary. Absolutely, yeah, yeah, you're right. And that is the toughest part. The anticipation is the toughest part.
并且意识到我恐高。我的意思是，我记得当我还是个小孩子的时候，我的意思是，实际上把第一只脚迈出台阶时有一种恐惧，你知道的，因为某种程度上，在你抓住梯子的第一个横档之前，你把它悬空荡了出去。而且它是，我的意思是，这很吓人。绝对的，是的，是的，你是对的。那是最难的部分。预期是最难的部分。
So I understand that this fear did not necessarily dissipate as you became an adult. How did it stay with you as you grew older, Arash? I remember if, let's say, we went for a hiking, I would really avoid any edge that could expose me to being able to see below if the decline was not gradual. Or when I came to America and I bought my house, of course there are addicts here. We don't have addicts in my house in Iran, but here I couldn't go up the ladder to go to the attic. Or trying to replace light bulb was a big challenge for me. And so it stayed with me. I remember probably about 10 years ago I was with a friend, we were jogging in Ann Arbor and we were alongside the river and then she basically wanted to show me
所以我听说这种恐惧在你成年后并没有完全消散。随着你年龄的增长，这种恐惧是如何伴随你的，阿拉什？我记得如果，比方说，我们去远足，我会极力避开任何可能让我看到下面如果斜坡不是逐渐变缓的边缘。或者当我来到美国并买下我的房子时，当然这里有阁楼。我在伊朗的家里没有阁楼，但在这里我无法爬梯子去阁楼。或者试图更换灯泡对我来说是一个巨大的挑战。所以它一直伴随着我。我记得大概10年前我和一个朋友在一起，我们在安娜堡慢跑，我们沿着河边走，然后她基本上想带我去看
this little tiny island in the river where there was a tree log connecting the mainland to that tiny island, probably like 10 feet long. She just ran on it like it gets well and she was on the island. And again, it was a reminder to me that I am afraid of heights. And the water below me was probably again 8 to 10 feet below, but I needed a lot of encouragement to get to the other side. Did you have to sort of hold your arms out and walk very carefully? How did you manage to get across the log? Embarrassingly, I was basically on my four limbs. I was crawling on this log to get to the other side. So your experience on the tree trunk may have been embarrassing, but ultimately it was fairly
河里那个很小的小岛，那里有一根树桩连接着大陆和那个小岛，大概有10英尺长。她就像踩得很稳一样在上面跑，然后她就到了岛上。再次，这提醒了我，我是恐高的。我下方的水可能又是8到10英尺深，但我需要大量的鼓励才能到达另一边。你是不是得把双臂伸开，走得非常小心？你是怎么设法穿过那根树干的？尴尬的是，我基本上是四肢着地。我在这根圆木上爬过去到达另一边。你在树干上的经历可能很尴尬，但最终它相当
minor. Fjord can also hold people back in far more serious situations. One tragic example unfolded in Parkland, Florida in February 2018 when we experienced a school shooting. Can you set the scene for me and paint me a picture of what happened, Arash? So the school shooting was happening and the sound of a gun going off was coming out,
微不足道。恐惧也可能在严重得多的情况下阻碍人们。一个悲惨的例子在2018年2月佛罗里达州帕克兰展开，当时我们经历了校园枪击案。你能为我还原现场，描绘一下发生了什么吗，阿拉什？所以校园枪击案正在发生，枪声不断传出，
and one of the security officers who was at the school, he was very slow and kind of paralyzed in responding to the threat, was outside the building and ended up not taking action in a timely manner. He was armed, but he took shelter in an alcove outside the building and waited for help to arrive, even as the shooting was taking place inside the building.
学校的一名保安反应非常缓慢，面对威胁时几乎瘫痪，他在大楼外面，最终没有及时采取行动。他带着枪，但他在大楼外面的一个凹室里躲避，等待救援到达，甚至在枪击事件在大楼内部发生时也是如此。
So he didn't go in and confront the shooter. Yeah, that's correct. And of course, I was not in the head of this person, but I could just imagine, if I go in, what's going to happen to me? What's going to happen to the kids? Will I by mistake shoot someone else? Do I know what I should be doing?
所以他没有进去与枪手对抗。是的，没错。当然，我不在这个人的脑海里，但我可以想象，如果我进去，我会发生什么？孩子们会发生什么？我会不会误伤别人？我知道我该做什么吗？
Will I be judged and criticized afterwards? And of course, all the bodily reactions which are there at the site of the terror. And it goes back to the biology and psychology of fear. This is a very, very strong force and energy within us. It's one of our deepest and most primitive emotions, which functions at many different levels from very basic primitive animal fear brain,
事后我会不会受到评判和批评？当然，还有身处恐怖现场时所有的身体反应。这就回到了恐惧的生物学和心理学。这是我们体内一股非常、非常强大力量和能量。它是我们最深层、最原始的情感之一，在许多不同的层面上运作，从非常基础原始的动物恐惧大脑，
which is, okay, now gunshot, loud noise, danger, to the highest level of human processing. And there's a lot of thoughts, plus the biology at play at the moment. So Arash, you're a psychiatrist specializing in the treatment of stress, trauma and anxiety which means that you help people who are afflicted with very severe anxieties and fears. Some of your patients have seen their lives become very constricted as a result of their fears. For one patient, I understand his descent into fear
也就是，好吧，现在有枪声、巨响、危险，到人类处理的最高水平。此时此刻，有很多想法以及生物学机制在起作用。所以阿拉什，你是一位专门治疗压力、创伤和焦虑的精神病学家，这意味着你帮助那些深受严重焦虑和恐惧折磨的人。你的一些患者由于他们的恐惧，生活变得非常局限。对于其中一位患者，我了解到他陷入恐惧的深渊
began when he got laid off from his job. Can you tell me his story? Yeah, so right after college, this bright kid immediately gets a job, he enjoys the job, he has a circle of friends, mostly work related, they hang out together, and then he's laid off. So then he searches for work a little bit and he finds a job that he can do from home and remotely.
始于他被公司解雇。你能讲讲他的故事吗？好的，就在大学毕业后，这个聪明的孩子立刻找到了一份工作，他很喜欢这份工作，他有一个朋友圈，大多与工作相关，他们常在一起闲逛，然后他被解雇了。于是他找了一段时间的工作，找到了一份可以在家远程做的工作。
And gradually he starts losing some of his social skills. He loses that circle of friends, he doesn't have other people outside, and then he loses this job also and starts a full period of self-doubt. And then panic attacks start. And panic, the way it works, is just totally out of a blue. There is a full storm of fear. The most extreme form of fear someone can experience in their mind and in the body. Heart pounding, breathing is difficult.
渐渐地，他开始失去一些社交技能。他失去了那个朋友圈，外面没有其他人，然后他也失去了这份工作，并开始了一段充满自我怀疑的时期。接着恐慌发作开始了。而恐慌的发作方式，完全是毫无征兆的。那是一场恐惧的风暴。一个人在精神和身体上所能体验到的最极端的恐惧形式。心跳加速，呼吸困难。
So it's very terrifying to people, especially if they don't know what's happening. And this happened to coincide with driving. So then his brain associated driving with danger. Slow down on driving and at some point stop driving. Then he started to have panic attacks in social situations, started avoiding going to places, first places which were more crowded and then more and more basically generalized situations even like a grocery store.
所以这让人感到非常恐惧，特别是如果他们不知道发生了什么的话。而这恰好与开车的时间巧合。于是他的大脑将开车与危险联系在一起。减少开车，并在某个时候停止开车。然后他开始在社交场合恐慌发作，开始避免去一些地方，首先是比较拥挤的地方，然后基本上是越来越多普遍的情况，甚至像杂货店。
And let's say another time had a panic attack while showering and now brain associated, shopping in the shower with the panic attack. So started basically increased the intervals of his showers and then now hygiene is not great. So that was another layer of lowering self-esteem and not going out. So by the time I met this person in his mid 40s,
比方说另一次洗澡时恐慌发作，现在大脑就把在浴室里购物与恐慌发作联系起来了。于是开始基本上拉长了他洗澡的间隔时间，现在卫生状况也不太好。那是降低自尊和不出门的又一个层面。所以当我遇到这个四十多岁的人时，
he was basically housebound, dysfunctional, spending all his day on the couch. Sometimes our fears can feel bigger and stronger than we are. They hold us back from doing what we want to do, what we know we ought to do. When we come back, how understanding the psychology of fear can teach us when to listen to it and how to control it. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
他基本上足不出户，丧失功能，整天泡在沙发上。有时我们的恐惧会让我们觉得比自己更大、更强。它们阻碍我们去做我们想做的事，去做我们知道我们应该做的事。广告之后，了解恐惧的心理学如何教导我们何时倾听它以及如何控制它。您正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. If you peer down the long corridors of evolution, you will see that there are many aspects of the brain that have changed over time. But researchers find that the neural pathways that govern fear are highly preserved across species. You can find them in rodents, in antelopes, and in humans. There is a simple reason for this.
这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。如果你顺着漫长的进化长廊回望，你会发现大脑的许多方面随着时间发生了变化。但研究人员发现，控制恐惧的神经回路在不同物种之间高度保守。你可以在啮齿动物、羚羊和人类身上找到它们。这有一个简单的原因。
Creatures who lack the capacity for fear did reckless things and were quickly removed from the gene pool. The survivors were the ones who had a healthy capacity for fear, and they passed their genes to us. But what this means is that we all have fear circuits in our brains that were sculpted in the Stone Age. What worked for our ancestors may not always work for us. Psychiatrist Arash Chavanbakth has studied what fear does to us. He believes that understanding the mechanisms of fear can help us form a wiser relationship
缺乏恐惧能力的生物会做出鲁莽的事情，并很快被基因库淘汰。幸存下来的是那些具有健康恐惧能力的人，他们把基因传给了我们。但这意味着我们的大脑中都有在石器时代塑造的恐惧回路。对我们的祖先有效的方法可能并不总是对我们有效。精神病学家阿拉什·贾凡巴赫特研究了恐惧对我们做了什么。他认为理解恐惧的机制可以帮助我们与这种古老的情感建立更明智的关系。
with this ancient emotion. Arash, I understand that a number of years ago you were sitting in your parked car when something very dramatic happened to you. Tell me what happened. So this happened early in medical school. We were near the University Hospital with a few of my classmates. We were getting ready to go to funeral
阿拉什，我听说几年前你坐在停着的车里时，发生了一件非常戏剧性的事情。告诉我发生了什么。所以这件事发生在刚上医学院的时候。我们和几个同学在大学医院附近。我们正准备去参加
of one of our classmates' mother. And all of a sudden, this motorcycle, riding very fast, just plows through the driver's side door. Wow. And I'm so happy nobody was injured, luckily and miraculously, but basically the two doors on the left were just totally damaged. But what I remember was it's as if I'm seeing a slow motion movie. And right now, 20-some years later, you and I are talking, I see the image right in front
我们一位同学的母亲的葬礼。突然之间，这辆摩托车开得非常快，直接撞碎了驾驶员侧的车门。哇。我很庆幸没有人受伤，幸运且奇迹般地，基本上左侧的两扇门彻底受损了。但我记得的是，就好像我在看一部慢动作电影。现在，20多年过去了，你和我正在交谈，那个画面依然浮现在我眼前
of me. And I see how slowly that bike is coming towards me. Basically, slow motion with full attention. And then I saw, even I remember the guy's face as the bike was getting closer and they hit the door on my side. So you clearly had a chance to look up and see him coming toward you.
我看到那辆摩托车朝我开过来是多么缓慢。基本上是全神贯注的慢动作。然后我看到了，我甚至还记得摩托车越来越近时那个家伙的脸，以及他们撞到我这一侧的车门。所以你显然有机会抬头看到他朝你开过来。
I'm assuming you didn't have enough time at this point to actually get out of the way or start the car or move the car. What you're describing happening in slow motion, of course, probably happened in a couple of seconds or even a fraction of a second. Absolutely. I couldn't do anything. The car wasn't even on and I just saw a scared face and then boom. That was all I saw but in a very slow motion and being aware of all the even the colors of what's going on around what time of the day was basically my brain registered all the context and accused that were there. So why does this happen Arash? When we have these very dramatic things happen to us I think many of us have these moments
我假设当时你没有足够的时间真正避开，或者启动车子，或者移动车子。你刚才描述的慢动作发生的场景，当然可能发生在几秒钟甚至几分之一秒内。绝对的。我什么也做不了。车甚至都没发动，我只看到一张惊恐的脸，然后轰的一声。这就是我看到的全部，但以一种非常慢的动作进行，并且意识到周围发生的一切甚至颜色的细节，是一天中的什么时间，基本上我的大脑记录了所有的背景和线索。那么为什么会这样，阿拉什？当我们发生这些非常戏剧性的事情时，我想我们很多人都有过这种几乎带有电影感的时刻，
that almost feel cinematic, where everything seems to slow down and we can see things in great clarity, but there's nothing that we can do about it. Why do you think this is happening? What is happening inside our brains? So fear has a very long story with us, and we have to understand the context
一切似乎都慢了下来，我们可以非常清晰地看到事物，但我们对此却无能为力。你认为为什么会这样？我们的大脑内部发生了什么？所以恐惧和我们有着很长的故事，我们必须理解它进化的背景。
within which it evolved. And the context within which fear evolved was a context of physical threats. We had to worry about a predator, another human attacking us, or falling rock or natural disaster. So the system is designed to react very fast to the dangers that are around us. And when the system is activated, the brain regions involved in fear processing, including the amygdala and the sympathetic nervous system, basically it was not that the environment slowed down, I sped up. So my processing speeds up, my attention becomes hyper focused
而恐惧进化的背景是身体威胁的背景。我们必须担心捕食者、另一个攻击我们的人、落石或自然灾害。所以这个系统旨在对我们周围的危险做出非常快速的反应。当这个系统被激活时，涉及恐惧处理的大脑区域，包括杏仁核和交感神经系统，基本上不是环境变慢了，而是我变快了。所以我的处理速度加快了，我的注意力变得高度集中，
and the memory becomes stronger. So we register such experiences even more crisp and more strongly. And that by itself has an evolutionary purpose because if something is dangerous, if something is a threat, I should register and learn it so well that the next time if this is about to happen, let's say, instead of the motorcycle approaching me very fast, it was a grizzly bear.
记忆也变得更强。所以我们对这种经历的记录更加清晰和强烈。这本身就具有进化的目的，因为如果有什么是危险的，如果有什么是威胁，我应该把它记录下来并学得如此透彻，以至于下一次如果这即将发生，比方说，不是摩托车向我高速驶来，而是一只灰熊。
And I was attacked by a bear as a tribal human 50,000 years ago. It would be very dumb for me for the second time to go try to pet the next grizzly bird that I met. So it registers in my brain so well that this is dangerous, you got to be careful and also learn whatever skill you need to avoid at the next time. Oroch, when you describe the motorcycle approach in slow motion. It sounded like you were frozen in place. You couldn't do anything but watch the crash unfold. Why does the sense of paralysis sometimes strike us when we feel very afraid?
而在5万年前作为一个原始人类的我遭到了一只熊的袭击。如果第二次遇到下一只遇到的灰熊时我还去试图抚摸它，那就太愚蠢了。所以它非常完美地记录在我的脑海里，这是危险的，你必须小心，还要学会下一次需要避免的任何技能。阿拉什，当你用慢动作描述摩托车驶近时。听起来你就像被冻结在原地了一样。除了看着撞车事故展开，你什么也做不了。为什么当我们感到非常害怕时，有时会有这种瘫痪感？
And that's another amazing aspect of fear. So we have the fight response, flight response, and the freeze response. Freeze response has been seen mostly in animals which are prey. For example, a rabbit spots a hawk, and the rabbit freezes because it doesn't want to be seen. So basically the brain paralyzes the system, so the motion is minimal. For humans, we are more of the predatorial animal, and that's why freeze response is less often observed.
这也是恐惧的一个神奇方面。所以我们有战斗反应、逃跑反应和冻结反应。冻结反应主要在作为猎物的动物身上看到。例如，一只兔子发现了一只鹰，兔子会僵住，因为它不想被看到。所以基本上大脑使系统瘫痪，这样运动就降到了最低。对于人类来说，我们更多是掠夺性动物，这就是为什么冻结反应观察得较少。
But when there is no other option, you try to basically minimize the risks and minimize the resources and minimize the chances of more harm by freezing. And we see this reaction in a lot of horrible situations where humans are stuck, like rape and assault and torture, that they cannot do anything else. So the best option is to not do anything to at least, let's say, going back to the evolutionary context, reduce the amount of bleeding. So you've given me some very dramatic examples where freezing happens. You know, a predator is attacking its prey or a human being is being attacked by another
但当没有其他选择时，你通过冻结来尽量减少风险、减少资源消耗并减少受到更多伤害的机会。我们在许多人类陷入困境的恐怖情况中看到了这种反应，比如强奸、袭击和酷刑，他们做不了其他任何事情。所以最好的选择是什么也不做，至少，比方说回到进化的背景下，减少流血量。你已经给我举了一些非常戏剧性的冻结发生的例子。你知道，捕食者在攻击猎物，或者一个人被另一个人攻击，非常戏剧性的情况。冻结也会发生在不那么戏剧性的情况中吗，涉及心理危机的场景？
person, very dramatic situations. Can freezing also happen in less dramatic situations, situations involving psychological peril? Absolutely. We talked about how this system has evolved to react to very physical situations of danger. But what you're coming to now is that in the modern life, majority of the threats that we are perceiving are so abstract. A few years ago, we were talking about this virus,
当然。我们讨论了这个系统是如何进化来对非常具体的身体危险情况做出反应的。但你现在要说到的是，在现代生活中，我们感知到的大多数威胁都是如此抽象。几年前，我们在谈论这个病毒，
which is spreading from China to Europe and gradually coming to America. It's a virus. We don't even see it. We just hear the news and we have to make decisions based on that. So, the system gets confused a lot of times. But also, there are situations that you pause to be able to process more. You pause because you cannot do anything else. Or it's a better self-preservation to not make a move when you do not know what is the move to make. In your work with many veterans, first responders, and refugees, you say that sometimes what happens is that not only are we afraid of the thing
它从中国传播到欧洲，逐渐来到美国。它是一种病毒。我们甚至看不到它。我们只是听到新闻，然后我们必须根据这些做出决定。所以，这个系统很多时候会感到困惑。但也有一些情况下，你会停顿下来以便处理更多信息。你停顿是因为你别无选择。或者在不知该采取什么行动时，不采取行动是更好的自我保护。在你与许多退伍军人、急救人员和难民的工作中，你说有时发生的情况是，我们不仅害怕最初引起我们恐惧的事物，我们还开始将恐惧推广到可能也是触发我们恐惧的类似事物上。你说这些急救人员和退伍军人中的许多人在美国的一个节日里经常有可怕的经历。那个节日是什么，阿拉什？独立日。所以这种恐惧的泛化同样是一种进化的优势。正如你所说，一只灰熊攻击了我或者我的一个同伴。
that originally caused our fear, we start to generalize across similar things that might also be a trigger for our fear. And you say that many of these first responders and veterans often have frightening experiences when it comes to one holiday in the United States. What is that holiday, Orozh? Fourth of July. So this generalization of fear is again an evolutionary advantage. As you said, a grizzly bear attacks me or one of my tripe mates.
现在我不仅避开灰熊，还避开黑熊。或者一只狼攻击了我。现在我避开所有不同种类的狼。对于那些经历过战争、或经历过爆炸、枪支暴力或枪击事件的人来说，巨大的噪音与可怕而危险的事情联系在一起。现在任何不可预测的巨响都会产生同样的反应，大脑将对任何巨响的恐惧反应过度泛化了，无论是关门声还是烟花。这就是为什么许多退伍军人和战区幸存者，在7月4日那天感到无比恐慌，
Now I avoid not only grizzly bears, but also black bears. Or a wolf attacks me. Now I avoid all different kinds of wolves. And for people who have been in war or near explosions or gun violence or shootings, the loud noise is associated with something horrific and dangerous. And now any unpredictable loud noise can create the same response and the brain over generalizes the fear response to any loud noise, whether it's the slamming door or the fireworks. And that's why a lot of veterans and survivors of convoy illness, they are terrified the 4th of
他们尽量戴上耳机、躲到地下室里，因为他们在逻辑上知道自己是安全的。这不是战争环境，也不是枪击背景。问题是我们在谈论大脑不符合逻辑的部分，它基本上通过联想来学习恐惧。我甚至遇到过退伍军人在7月4日听到烟花爆竹声时，直接倒在地上的情况。你提到你的一个患者的情况之一是，他大学毕业后非常成功，
July and they try to wear headphones, go to the basement because they logically know they are safe. This is not the war environment or this is not the shooting context. The problem is that we are talking about the illogical part of the brain, which basically learns fear through association. And I've had even veterans at the Uniforth of July when the firework goes off, just drop on the floor. One of the things that you mentioned about the patient you had, who was very successful coming out of college,
但渐渐开始自我封闭，恐惧往往会导致我们逃避那些让我们感到恐惧的事物。你能讲讲你的一个患者在加油站被抢劫以及这后来对患者生活的影响的故事吗？好的，当危险的事情发生时，这些高度危险痛苦的情况会被非常强烈地记录下来。所以对这个人来说，抢劫发生时，他们在加油站，
but gradually started to withdraw into himself, is that fear tends to cause us to avoid the things that made us fearful. Can you tell me the story of one of your patients who was robbed at a gas station and the effect this later on had on the patient's life. Yeah, so when something dangerous happens, these highly dangerous painful situations are very strongly registered. So for this person, when the robbing happened, they were in the gas station,
他们正要上车，有人拿着枪指着他们，然后抢走了他们的钱。这非常可怕。现在这个大脑想要阻止这种情况再次发生。和灰熊的故事一样。我不想再次被灰熊攻击并失去另一只肢体。所以现在大脑不仅试图收集关于熊的数据，还试图收集关于背景的数据。这发生在什么背景下？树林的那一个角落，那里有熊。我再也不应该去那里了。这里也一样。这是一个
they were just about to get in their car, Somebody comes pointing a gun at them and then takes their money. This was very terrifying. And now this brain wants to prevent this from happening again. The same story as the grizzly bear. I don't want to be attacked by a grizzly bear again and lose another limb to them. So now the brain tries to collect not only data about the bear but also about the context. In what context did this happen? That corner of the woods, there are bears there. I shouldn't go there anymore. Same applies here. It was a
加油站，时间是一天中的这个时候。所以联想变成了这里的加油站对这个人来说。避开加油站，发现去那里非常困难，这是自动的。从逻辑上讲，他们知道拿枪的那个人不在这个加油站，现在甚至可能附近有警察，但他们觉得很难。渐渐地，这会扩大到便利店。或者那一天中的那个时间，对许多人来说，是发生这一切的一天中的那个时间或一年中的那个时间，焦虑会增加。因为令人惊奇的是，背景不仅是物理背景，还有社会背景，
gas station, it was at this time of the day. So the association becomes the gas stations here for this person. Avoiding gas stations, finding it very difficult going there, and it's automatic. Logically they know that the guy with the gun is not at this gas station, now there may even be cops nearby, but they find it difficult. Gradually they can expand to convenience stores. Or that time of the day, for a lot of people, it's the time of the day or the time of the year that this happened, that the anxiety increases. Because amazingly, the context is not just the physical context, but also social context,
以及时间背景。从进化的角度来看，假设你在树林的一个地方遇到了一熊。你现在会给那个区域留出很大的安全距离。你避开那个区域的次数越多，你的情况就会越好。但同样的适应在现代生活中可能意味着人们很快将自己从日常的意义和联系来源中切断。所以如果我们避开树林里的灰熊，我们每一次避开它都是一种好处。但挑战在于，我们学到的许多恐惧都是特定于背景的。
but also temporal context. From an evolutionary perspective, let's say you encounter a bear in one neck of the woods. You now give that area a wide berth. The more often you avoid that area, the better off you're going to be. But that same adaptation in the modern context can mean that people quickly cut themselves off from everyday sources of meaning and connection. So if we avoid a grizzly burr in the woods, every time we avoid it, it's a benefit. But the challenge is a lot of these fears that we have learned are context dependent.
战区或枪击环境中的巨响是一件危险的事情，对吧？在7月4日，这是一次有趣的经历。问题是，有时我们正在逃避的这个东西，例如，在这个例子中，新的其他加油站，并不是危险的。但它的运作方式是，我看到了，我吓坏了，因为大脑说，这很危险，你不应该去那里。你不去那里，什么坏事都没有发生。大脑说，你看，你避开了，什么坏事都没有发生。所以你应该继续避开。
A loud noise just in the war zone or in a shooting environment is a dangerous thing, right? On the 4th of July, it's a fun experience. The problem is that sometimes this thing that we are avoiding, for instance, now in this example, new other gas stations, it's not dangerous. But the way it works is that I see it, I freak out because the brain says, this is dangerous, you shouldn't go there. You don't go there, nothing bad happens. The brain says, you see, you avoided, nothing bad happens. So you should keep avoiding.
所以现在它会变得越来越难，而且它不断扩大、泛化和巩固恐惧，变得越来越强烈，我在其他患者的例子中看到过，它就像瘟疫一样在他们的生活中蔓延，并泛化到越来越多的其他情况下。我听说对于你的一位患者来说，甚至连一个热闹喧嚣的餐厅也成了危险的地方。告诉我这个人的世界是什么样的。我实际上在急救人员身上经常看到这一点。我和警察、消防员
So now it will become harder and harder and harder and it keeps expanding and generalizing and consolidating the fear and becomes stronger and I've seen it in other examples of patients how like a plague it expands through their life and it generalizes to other more and more and more and more conditions. I understand for one of your patients you know even a cheerful bustling restaurant has become a place of danger. Tell me what the world looks like for this person. So I see this actually a lot in first responders. I work a lot with cops and firefighters
以及紧急救援人员合作很多，在开始与他们合作之前，我不知道他们的生活有多艰难。压力太大了。他们的生活中发生了许多不可预测的危险。如果是一名警察，你去处理发生的枪击事件
and emergency personnel, and I didn't know how tough their lives are until I started working with them. There's a ton of stress. There's a lot of unpredictable dangers happening in their lives. And right if you're a police officer, you go to deal with the shooting that has happened
或者有家庭暴力、虐待，如果你是消防员，你去发生车祸的地方，你必须把人们从燃烧的车里拉出来。他们与退伍军人的区别在于，退伍军人去战区然后他们回到安全的平民环境中。对于急救人员来说，他们生活的环境与他们暴露在人类对彼此和对自己的最糟糕行为中的环境是同一个。
or there's been domestic violence, abuse, you're firefighter, you go to where there's been car crash, you have to pull people out of the burning cars. And the difference they have, let's say with veterans, is that a veteran goes to a war zone and then they come back to the safe civilian environment. For first responders, the same environment where they live is the same environment they are exposed to the worst of what humans do to each other and to themselves.
所以他们的大脑会自动进入战斗和逃跑状态，不断地扫描危险。他们可能在同一家餐厅里逮捕或对某人进行过心肺复苏，现在他们想和家人一起去那里。所以当他们去那个地方时，他们中的许多人，当那里有很多人时，如果他们去，他们会坐在背靠墙的某个地方，
So their brain automatically goes to the state of fight and flight constantly screening for danger. And they could have arrested or done a CPR on someone in the same restaurant now they want to go through their family. So when they go to the place, a lot of them, by the time that there are many people there, and if they go, they will sit somewhere with their back to the wall,
在那里他们可以看到一切并观察出口，所以这基本上变成了一种自动的安全行为。恐惧通过扭曲可怕的事物、将其放大来发挥作用。再次强调，这在生存是挑战且避开威胁比寻找机会更重要的背景下运作良好。但我们今天的许多恐惧与生存问题无关。搞砸一次演讲、烤砸一道砂锅菜，或者在约会时被拒绝，与
where they can watch everything and watch the exits, and so it basically becomes an automatic safety behavior. Fear works by distorting the thing that is fearful, by magnifying it. Again, this worked well in a context where survival was a challenge and avoiding threats was a far more important priority than seeking out opportunities. But many of our fears today are not connected with matters of survival. Messing up a speech, burning a casserole, or being rejected by a date, are not in the same league
面对一只饥饿的老虎根本不是同一个级别的。当我们把微不足道的危险当作威胁生命的危险来对待时，这会扭曲我们生活中的一切。所以很多时候恐惧，正如你所说，扭曲了我们的注意力。所以当我害怕时，让我举个例子。我去上一门我正在教的课，我已经感到非常害怕了
as being confronted by a hungry tiger. When we treat trivial dangers the same as life-threatening dangers, this can skew everything in our lives. So a lot of times fear, as you said, distorts our attention. So when I'm scared, let me just bring an example. I go to a class that I'm teaching and I already am terrified
我可能不是一个好的演讲者，我可能不是一个好的教授，或者我已经对公开演讲有了一些恐惧，实际上我的很多患者都有过这种情况。所以我走进这间教室，我顿时觉得信心不足，我的心脏在砰砰直跳，呼吸困难，我可能会出一点汗，
that I may not be a good speaker, I may not be a good professor, or I already have some fear of public speaking and I have actually had this in a lot of my patients. So I go into this class and I already feel less confident, my heart is pounding, my breathing is difficult, I might be a little bit sweaty,
我的注意力有点分散和扭曲，然后令人惊奇的是，我的大脑处于战斗和逃跑模式以及威胁检测模式，所以我的注意力集中在环境中的任何信号和线索上。这可能表明事情进展不顺利。比方说我的一个学生在玩手机，我会认为他们在给另一个学生发短信，
my attention is a little bit distracted and distorted, and then the amazing thing about it is that my brain is in fight and flight mode and threat detection, so my attention is focused on any signal and cue from the environment. That might suggest that things are not going well. Let's say for one of my students is on their phone, I will think that they are texting another student
说我是一个多么糟糕的老师。如果另一个人在使用他们的电脑，即使他们是在记我演讲的笔记，我也会认为他们觉得无聊。如果有人双手交叉坐着，我认为他们现在有了戒心。这让我对自己更加缺乏自信或信心，我对他们的反应可能会显得笨拙。
about how bad of a teacher I am. If another one is on their computer, even though if they are taking notes from my speech, I may think that they're bored. If someone is sitting with their arms crossed, I think they are now guarded. So that makes me become more or less confident in myself and my reaction to them may become awkward.
他们开始想，这家伙怎么了？他为什么表现得这么笨拙？渐渐地，这基本上创造了一个自我实现的预言循环，因为我们已经设定了期望，即这个世界和这个环境是危险的。而这其他人，我们实际上看到了这一点，我经常提出的例子是社交焦虑症患者，例如，他们走出去，认为外面的每个人都在试图评判他们。每当他们看到任何表明其他人赞赏他们的迹象时，大脑基本上
And they start thinking, what's wrong with this guy? Why is he acting awkwardly? And gradually this basically creates a self-fulfilling prophecy cycle because we already set the expectation that this world and this environment is dangerous. And these other people, and we see this actually, the example I brought up a lot of times in people with social anxiety, for example, they go out thinking everyone out there is trying to judge them. And anytime they see any sign that other people appreciate them, the brain basically
会把这当作噪音尖叫过去。但任何可以被解释的迹象，甚至是中性的迹象，表明有危险或某些人在评判我，或者他们不喜欢我，或者我做了什么蠢事而他们不喜欢，都会影响我对外在事物的感知、对自己的感知以及我自己的行为。稍后回来，我们将讨论克服不合理恐惧的策略，这些策略可以让我们朝着对我们重要的目标和活动迈进。您正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。
screams this out as noise. But any sign that can be interpreted, even neutral signs as there's something dangerous or some people are judging me or they don't like me or I did something dumb and they didn't like it, that will affect basically my perception of other people and my perception of myself and my own behavior. When we come back, strategies for overcoming unwarranted fears that can allow us to move toward goals and activities that are important to us. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。我刚才告诉过你，歌手卡莉·西蒙如何在1981年的现场演出中经历了非常戏剧性的舞台恐惧症。多年以后，她的恐惧让她不敢在观众面前唱歌。然而，在1987年，她再次登上了舞台。在一场精心策划的活动中，她在她多年来一直为之家的海滨社区的一个小型本地人群面前进行了表演。这场音乐会取得了巨大的成功。
I'm Shankar Vedantan. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. I told you earlier about how the singer Karli Simon suffered a very dramatic experience of stage fright while performing live in 1981. Her fear kept her from singing in front of an audience for many years afterwards. In 1987, however, she ventured on stage again. In a carefully planned event, she performed before a small, local crowd in the seaside community that had been her home for many years. The concert was a triumph.
精神病学家阿拉什·贾凡巴赫特帮助了许多人防止恐惧摧毁他们的生活。他是《害怕：理解恐惧的目的并驾驭焦虑的力量》（Afraid, Understanding the Purpose of Fear and Harnessing the Power of Anxiety）一书的作者。阿拉什，你曾说过，通往勇敢的道路不是消除恐惧，而是与恐惧合作。你这个想法是什么意思？所以勇敢和勇气是在对个人来说困难和具有挑战性的情况下定义的，但个人能够克服那种原始的动物反应并采取行动。有时这基本上是一种自我牺牲，这可能是合乎逻辑的。
Psychiatrist Arash Javanbhakt has helped many people keep fear from destroying their lives. He is the author of Afraid, Understanding the Purpose of Fear and Harnessing the Power of Anxiety. Arash, you've said that the path to becoming brave is not to eliminate fear but to work with it. What do you mean by this idea? So bravery and courage are defined in situations which are difficult and challenging for the person, but the person is able to overcome that primitive animal reaction and take their eye into action. Sometimes it's basically a self-sacrifice, which could be logical.
我记得的案例是，有一名消防员和他的搭档、他的同事被困在大楼里。这个人决定另外两个人应该先走，并把他们推出去，帮助他们逃离大楼，而他自己死了。所以这是一个勇敢的行动，但有很多行动从外面听起来可能很勇敢，但可能只是一种冲动的行动，对吧？我的意思是，有趣的是，我认为我们把勇气和无所畏惧作为同义词，
The case I remember is there was a firefighter who was stuck with his partner with his colleagues inside a building. And this person decides that the other two should go first and pushes them out and helps them out of the building and he dies. So this is a brave action, but then there are a lot of actions that might sound brave from outside, but could just be an impulsive action, right? I mean, it's interesting that I think we use the words courage and fearlessness synonymously,
但在某些方面，勇气不仅仅是没有恐惧，对吗？不，不是的。事实上，要做到无所畏惧，基本上，一个人需要没有某种基因构成，或者基本上脑损伤导致了体验恐惧的能力丧失。否则，我们所有正常的凡人都经历着恐惧，就像我们经历恐惧一样。否则，我们所有正常的凡人都经历着恐惧
but in some ways, courage is not merely the absence of fear, is it? No, it's not. Actually, to be fearless, basically, one needs to not have a make-up, or basically brain damage leads to an ability to experience fear. Otherwise, all of us normal humans do experience fear the same way we experience fear. Otherwise, all of us, normal humans, do experience fear
就像我们经历痛苦一样。当然，有些事情可以帮助我们变得更强大、准备更充分。所以，准确的威胁感知，对吧？我看到一条蛇，我吓坏了。作为动物学家的某人看到那条蛇，他们会想，我们在密歇根州，密歇根州有毒蛇的普及率非常低。然后当然，我
the same way we experience pain. Well, of course, there are things that help us be stronger, be more prepared. So, accurate threat perception, right? I see a snake, I freak out. Someone as a zoologist sees that snake and they're like, well, we are in Michigan, Michigan, the prevalence of poisonous venomous snakes is very low. And then of course, I'm
看着这条蛇，我知道这条蛇是没有毒的。所以在我看来他们非常勇敢。但这里发生的事情是，他们只是拥有知识，或者某人受过训练，某人有控制感或目标感。所以有这么多不同的方面构成了勇敢的行动。我们可以花一点时间来讨论你刚才提出的这个想法吗，即培养勇敢和勇气的主要方法之一，来支撑我们的安全感，就是对正在发生的事情有一种控制感。
looking at this snake and I know this snake is not venomous. So they look very brave to me. But what is happening here is that they just have knowledge or someone has training, someone has a sense of control or sense of purpose. So there's so many different aspects that come into a brave action. Can we just spend a moment on this idea that you just brought up, which is one major way of cultivating bravery and courage to shore up our feelings of safety is to have a sense of control over what's happening.
在某种程度上，也许正是控制感让卡莉·西蒙在1987年的那一天重返舞台。你能谈谈这个想法吗，在某种程度上，控制感是什么让卡莉·西蒙在1987年的那一天重返舞台。你能谈谈这个想法吗，在某种程度上，恐惧从我们这里偷走的是我们对正在发生的事情的控制感，如果我们重新获得控制感，在某种程度上我们就重新获得了对恐惧本身的控制感？这是处理恐惧最重要的方面之一。在正常寻常的可怕情况下，
And in some ways, maybe a sense of control is what allowed Carly Simon to return to the stage on that day in 1987. Can you just talk about this idea that in some ways, what of control is what allowed Carly Simon to return to the stage on that day in 1987. Can you just talk about this idea that in some ways what fear steals from us is our sense of control over what is happening and if we regain a sense of control, in some ways we get a sense of control over the fear itself? This is one of the most important aspects of dealing with fear. In normal usual scary situations,
是的，正是这种控制感让我觉得我可以对此做点什么。比方说，当大流行开始时，我们对如何保护自己一无所知。然后有人来，说，好吧，这里有一个口罩，这里有一种疫苗可以降低生病的几率。我们开始感到更有信心
yes, that is the sense of control that allows me to feel I can do something about it. Let's say when the pandemic started, we didn't know anything about how we can protect ourselves. Then some came and said, okay, there's a mask here, there's a vaccine here that reduces the chance of getting sick. And we started feeling a lot more confident
因为现在我们有了一些控制力。我们可以做一些事情来帮助我们防范危险。而获得这种控制感的一种方法是获得知识来准备、教育、学习我们可以应对我们所害怕的情况的方法。学习所做的不仅仅是简单地为我们提供知识。当我们学习时，我们的思维方式发生了改变。
because now we had some control. We could do things that could help us protect ourselves against the danger. And the one way of gaining the sense of control is gaining the knowledge to prepare, educate, learn ways we can deal with the situations we are afraid of. Learning does more than simply provide us with knowledge. When we are learning, our mindset changes.
我们的情感风暴平静了下来。阿拉什将这种真知灼见运用到帮助一位患者克服对鲨鱼的恐惧中。所以这个人喜欢游泳和冲浪，他们喜欢去加利福尼亚去海滩冲浪和游泳。但他们太害怕鲨鱼了。有趣的是，这种恐惧始于他们年轻时看了电影《大白鲨》。当然，这些恐惧是不符合逻辑的。这个人甚至来到我的办公室说，
Our emotional storms quiet down. Arash brought this insight to bear as he helped one patient deal with the fear of sharks. So this person loved swimming and surfing and they would love to go to California and go on the beach and do surfing and swimming. But they were so terrified of sharks. And interestingly, this fear started when they were younger and they watched the movie Jaws. And of course, these fears are not logical. The person even comes to my office and says,
我们的情绪风暴平息了下来。阿拉什在帮助一位患者克服对鲨鱼的恐惧时，运用了这一见解。这个人非常喜欢游泳和冲浪，他们很想去加利福尼亚州的海滩冲浪和游泳。但他们对鲨鱼感到无比恐惧。有趣的是，这种恐惧始于他们年轻时看了电影《大白鲨》。当然，这些恐惧是不合逻辑的。这个人甚至来到我的办公室说，
I know it's stupid, but I'm afraid of this or that. To which I answer, it's not stupid. It's illogical. We have a logical way of processing and we have the illogical or associative way. So how about we start learning about sharks? How about we learn about which ones are dangerous? Because not all sharks are dangerous to humans. Which ones are dangerous? Which ones are not? Where are those dangerous sharks? What are the chances and the beach here that I go, there are more or less of them. So not only learning about that environment allowed him to be more comfortable, okay, the kind of shark that is dangerous is never spotted on this beach, so I can probably go here. But also it becomes a kind of a curious interest
我知道这很蠢，但我总是担心这担心那。对此我的回答是，这并不蠢。这只是不符合逻辑。我们有一种符合逻辑的信息处理方式，还有一种不符合逻辑的或联想的方式。那么，我们何不开始了解鲨鱼呢？我们何不了解一下哪些鲨鱼是危险的？因为并非所有鲨鱼对人类都是危险的。哪些是危险的？哪些不是？那些危险的鲨鱼在哪里？我去的那个海滩遇到它们的几率是多少，那里的鲨鱼是多还是少？因此，了解那种环境不仅让他感到更加安心，比如“这种危险的鲨鱼在这个海滩从没被发现过，所以我大概可以去这里”，
which helped him every time engage and incorporate basically the cognitive brain to, and every time we bring the cognitive logical brain, whether it's through paying attention to things around us or doing something mindful or learning something or even labeling the emotions, the intensity of the emotions declines. So sometimes learning more about the thing that we fear can quell our feelings of panic, but sometimes the fear itself is unreasonable and needs to be reevaluated.
而且这还变成了一种好奇心，这在他每次参与并基本上调动认知大脑时都能提供帮助。每当我们带入认知逻辑大脑——无论是通过关注身边的事务、做正念练习、学习新知识，甚至是给情绪命名——情绪的强度都会下降。因此，有时多了解我们害怕的事物可以平息我们的恐慌感，但有时恐惧本身是不合理的，需要重新评估。
Like for example, when we are talking about public speaking instead of sharks, talk about this idea that sometimes our response to fear needs to be to reevaluate the fear itself. Yeah, and this happens a lot in anxious people with more abstract forms of fear experiences. For instance, how scary is failing an exam or not grading well on an exam or failing a job evaluation or failing an interview I'm doing, right?
比如，当我们谈论公众演讲而不是鲨鱼时，我们就会谈到这样一个观点：有时我们对恐惧的反应应该是重新评估恐惧本身。是的，这在焦虑症患者身上经常发生，他们面对的是更抽象形式的恐惧体验。例如，考试不及格、考试成绩不好、工作评估没通过，或者我正在进行的面试表现搞砸了，这些有多可怕？
For a lot of people who are anxious, you ask them which part was the most scary. They say the anticipation. So a lot of times I say look back in the past and see the past on average, what percent you overshoot the danger. Then I say cognitively try to bring it down. That's one way, basically knowing myself and knowing how scared I usually am compared to the reality. Let's look at the statistics and utilizing
对于许多焦虑的人来说，你问他们哪一部分最可怕。他们会说是预期。所以很多时候我会让他们回顾过去，看看在过去，平均而言，他们把危险放大了百分之多少。然后我让他们从认知上试着把这种恐惧感降下来。这是一种方法，基本上就是认识自己，了解与现实相比，我通常的恐惧程度有多高。让我们看看统计数据，并利用
all of these cognitive resources and tools allows us basically control and leash that animal fear response. Arash, psychologists have a name for this kind of reevaluation. They call it cognitive reappraisal. I understand that you were once prompted to engage in cognitive reappraisal by your boxing coach. So boxing started in my life when a friend of mine probably about 10 years ago dragged me to this fitness boxing gym. I first thought it's such a stupid thing just stand there and hit a bag but I just fell in love. It, first of all, was fitness boxing. Just hitting the bag, I found it a very good discharge
所有这些认知资源和工具，基本上能让我们控制并勒住那种动物性的恐惧反应。阿拉什，心理学家给这种重新评估起了一个名字。他们称之为认知重评。我听说你曾经在拳击教练的促使下进行过认知重评。所以拳击进入我的生活大概是在10年左右前，当时我的一位朋友把我拉到了一家健身拳击馆。我起初觉得这太蠢了，就站在那儿打沙袋，但我一下子就爱上了它。首先，这是健身拳击。光是击打沙袋，我就发现这是一种很好的宣泄方式，
of a lot of tension, being focused, and of course, good workout. And basically, I have a trainer, Reggie, is a boxer himself. And we have started basically sparring training, but we don't hit each other hard. So after so many years, 10 years of fitness boxing, I knew all the moves, and I'm not bad,
可以释放大量的紧张情绪，保持专注，当然也是很好的锻炼。基本上，我有一个教练雷吉，他本人就是一名拳击手。我们开始进行实战训练，但我们不会狠狠地打对方。所以在经历了这么多年的健身拳击后，10年了，我知道所有的动作，而且我打得还不错，
I glove up and I'm standing in front of him. All of a sudden, it's just like I time travel to when I was in school, standing in front of a bully. As a kid, I was never fit, I was never athletic, or smaller, so I was bullied a few times. So I see myself right in front of this bully. And I was like, wow Reggie, I'm just experiencing the whole my whole body experience that fear.
我戴上手套站在他面前。突然之间，就像我穿越回了上学的时候，站在一个霸凌者面前。作为小孩子时，我从来不强壮，也从不擅长运动，而且个子更小，所以我曾被霸凌过好几次。所以我看到自己就站在这个霸凌者面前。我说：“哇，雷吉，我正在经历整个——我整个身体都在体验那种恐惧。”
And he said, imagine if that child you were once was here today, how proud of you he would be. He basically made a beautiful connection. I time traveled there and he made a bridge between there and now. Yeah, it's almost like you were time traveling to your past and he was helping your past to time travel to you. Absolutely, such a beautiful way of saying it.
他说：“想象一下，如果你曾经的那位小孩今天来到这里，他会为你感到多么骄傲。”他基本上建立了一个美丽的连结。我穿越回了过去，而他在过去和现在之间架起了一座桥梁。是的，这几乎就像是你穿越回了你的过去，而他正帮助你的过去穿越来找你。绝对是的，真是个绝妙的说法。
And a lot of times we do this with patients in treatment that they're stuck in the past. Part of our animal brain doesn't understand time, doesn't understand the distinction between what happened there and then, what happens here and now, right? A person with let's say post-traumatic stress disorder, they have a flashback of the memory and now they have a panic attack. And one of the things we do in treatment is to put those memories in the context. That's in the past. Now we are here.
很多时候，我们在治疗中对病人也会这样做，他们被困在了过去。我们的动物大脑有一部分不懂时间，不懂得区分当时当地发生了什么，以及此时此地发生了什么，对吧？比方说，患有创伤后应激障碍的人，他们会闪回记忆，然后就会恐慌发作。我们在治疗中要做的事情之一，就是把这些记忆放回语境中。那是过去。现在我们在这里。
What did I learn? And now I'm a different person than that other person. I'm making basically these connections. You said it very beautifully. So when fear takes hold of us, we often get caught up in spirals of fearful thoughts and ruminations. Arash, you said that grounding ourselves in our bodies can help in moments like this. What do you mean?
我学到了什么？现在的我已经和当年的那个人不同了。我基本上在建立这些连结。你刚才说得太美妙了。因此，当恐惧攫住我们时，我们常常会陷入恐惧的想法和反刍的漩涡中。阿拉什，你曾说过，立足于我们的身体可以帮助我们度过这样的时刻。你这是什么意思？
Interestingly, I have started over the past few days doing this ice plunge. Basically, I got one of these buckets and there's ice in it. I mean, I was too lazy. I put it outside on the back porch in Michigan. It's already very cold, so I don't recommend the 25 degrees, but I have been able to sit in it for 30 seconds. During that time, I'm just here and now in my body. I'm not anywhere else.
有趣的是，在过去的几天里，我开始尝试这种冰水浸泡。基本上，我弄了其中一个水桶，里面装满了冰。我是说，我太懒了。我把它放在密歇根州后廊的外面。那里已经非常冷了，所以我并不推荐零下几度（25华氏度）的做法，但我已经能够在里面坐上30秒。在那段时间里，我只活在此时此地的身体里。我不在任何其他地方。
And the idea is that when I do mindfulness practices with my patient, I ask them, basically at the moment, listen very carefully and tell me how many sounds are in your environment. Then ask them to look around and tell me how many colors they're seeing around them. All shades of color. Right now, there's in front of me in my office,
这个想法是，当我与患者一起进行正念练习时，我会在当时要求他们非常仔细地倾听，并告诉我环境中一共有多少种声音。然后要求他们环顾四周，告诉我他们周围看到了多少种颜色。所有的色彩色调。此时此刻，在我的办公室里，正前方
there's a picture that I took in Alaska, which has a mountain and beautiful water and trees, and there's so many colors in this. Then I ask them to feel their shoes, feel every inch of the shoe where there's more pressure, less pressure, where the foot is touching the ground, where the foot is not even touching the shoe. And then this very tiny practice after we're done, I asked them, how much did you think about the past or the future?
有一张我在阿拉斯加拍的照片，上面有山脉、美丽的水景和树木，里面有非常多的颜色。然后我让他们去感受自己的鞋子，感受鞋子的每一英寸，哪里压力更大，哪里压力更小，脚在哪里接触地面，脚甚至没有接触到鞋子的哪个部位。接着，在完成这个非常微小的练习后，我问他们，你们刚才想了多少关于过去或未来的事？
The answer is no. The reality is that we as humans are capable of reflecting on the past and planning for the future, which is an amazing human capability that has made us very capable, but it has also plagued our lives because majority of the times we are not here, we are in the past or in the future. And mindfulness is a practice of bringing us to here and now because the reality is the only true moment in our lives is this very moment which most of the times is the safest moment. So you can use practicing mindfulness to bringing us to the here and now and ground us in here. And a lot of times that could be our body. I use the example of this colt plunge
答案是没有。现实情况是，我们人类既有能力反思过去，也有能力规划未来，这是一项惊人的、让我们变得能力非凡的人类能力，但它也一直困扰着我们的生活，因为大多数时候我们并不在这里，而是在过去或未来。正念是一种把我们带回此时此地的练习，因为现实是，我们生活中唯一真实的时刻就是当下这个时刻，而大多数时候这也是最安全的时刻。所以你可以通过练习正念，把我们带到此时此地，并在当下立足。很多时候，这个“当下”可以是我们的身体。我用这种冷水浸泡作为例子，
because at that moment, really I kind of think of anything else. And actually that's one way fear helps us. For me, with my fear of hardship, if I stand on the edge of a rock in Grand Canyon, even though I'm safe, I cannot at that moment think about anything else. So one of the best established clinical techniques
因为在那个时刻，我真的没法去想任何别的事情。实际上，这也是恐惧帮助我们的一种方式。对我来说，由于我恐高，如果我站在大峡谷的一块岩石边缘，尽管我很安全，但在那个时刻我无法去想任何其他事情。因此，临床上公认的减少无端恐惧的最佳技术之一，
to reduce unwarranted fear is known as exposure therapy. Can you tell me how that works, Arash? So we talked earlier about how my brain associates something to danger. And every time I avoid it, I reconciliate the fear and the idea and the belief that that thing is dangerous. So exposure therapy is the opposite of that. That we gradually, slowly, introduce the feared situation to the person.
被称为暴露疗法。阿拉什，你能告诉我这是如何运作的吗？我们之前讨论过我的大脑是如何将某些事物与危险联系起来的。每当我回避它，我就会强化这种恐惧，以及“那东西很危险”的想法和信念。所以暴露疗法与此相反，也就是我们循序渐进地、慢慢地将令人生畏的情境引入到当事人面前。
Let's say I'm afraid of dogs. So we can sit here in my office and forever talk about how and why dogs are safe. It's not going to work. It's not going to teach the animal brain. Animal brain learns through experience. So we gradually introduce the feared situation whether it's a dog, whether it's height, whether it's a public speaking,
比方说我害怕狗。所以我们可以坐在这里的办公室里，永远地讨论狗为什么安全以及它是如何安全的。这不会起作用。这无法教化动物大脑。动物大脑是通过经验来学习的。因此，我们逐渐引入令人害怕的情境，无论是狗、高度、公众演讲，
whether it's being around other people. I go in, I get terrified, nothing bad happens. I go in, I get terrified, nothing bad happens. Gradually, gradually, I develop a new learning that in this environment, in this context, I'm safe, which is paired with the sensor control because it's not forced upon the person, right? We don't throw a person with the dog in the room and close the door on them.
还是身处人群之中。我走进去，我吓得要死，但什么坏事也没有发生。我走进去，我吓得要死，但什么坏事也没有发生。渐渐地、渐渐地，我建立了一种新的认知：在这个环境中，在这个语境下，我是安全的。这与掌控感结合在一起，因为这不是强加给当事人的，对吧？我们不会把一个人和一只狗扔进房间然后把门关上。
It was their own agency. They took charge and did it. And of course, I, as a social safety cue, I'm there with them. And they gradually, this brain develops new learning, along with the sense of control, I could do it. And we say you should keep doing it until it becomes boring or just annoying. And that's it. So you've done some work using virtual technologies to help people extinguish their fears.
这是他们自己的自主选择。他们掌控了局面并完成了这件事。当然，作为社会安全信号，我和他们在一起。渐渐地，这个大脑连同掌控感一起，培养出了新的认知：我能做到。我们说你应该一直这样做，直到它变得无聊或只是令人厌烦。就是这样。所以你曾利用虚拟技术来帮助人们消除恐惧。
How does this work? What do you do? So, I'm very excited about this technology we have created. So, virtual reality, you wear these goggles, you're in a different world. But augmented reality, you wear these goggles, as imagine you're wearing a pair of sunglasses. You see what is exactly around you, and then on your desk you see a spider. So we combine the real and unreal and they make it more real and immersive. So we started this for exposure therapy. Let's say I have people with fear of spiders.
这是如何运作的？你们是怎么做的？所以，我对我们创造这项技术感到非常兴奋。所以，虚拟现实，你戴上这些护目镜，你就身处一个不同的世界中。但增强现实，你戴上这些护目镜，就像想象你戴着一副太阳镜。你看到的是你周围确切的环境，然后你在桌子上看到了一只蜘蛛。因此，我们将真实的与不真实的结合起来，让它变得更真实、更有沉浸感。所以我们开始将此用于暴露疗法。比方说我有一些害怕蜘蛛的人。
We put tiny spiders in the environment and gradually the spiders become bigger and more spiders, more colors of spiders so we can generalize. And of course it's not that easy. In the beginning it's just one tiny spider in the very far corner and they are terrified. What's amazing is that we have found the subjective responses and brain-autonomic responses to these virtual spiders are the same as a real spider.
我们在环境中放入小蜘蛛，慢慢地，蜘蛛变得越来越大，数量更多，蜘蛛的颜色也更多，这样我们就可以进行泛化。当然，这没那么容易。一开始，在极远的角落里只有一只小蜘蛛，他们就吓得要死。神奇的是，我们发现对这些虚拟蜘蛛的主观反应和大脑自主神经反应与真实蜘蛛是一样的。
So then we gradually advanced this to dogs and snakes. And now for people with post-traumatic stress disorder, they find it difficult to be around other people. Now, I have someone in my office wearing the goggles. A virtual door opens on the wall, humans of different race, sex, body type, behavior, walk in the room, starting to interact with the patient, and then the patient practices exposure.
所以后来我们逐渐将这推进到狗和蛇。现在，对于患有创伤后应激障碍的人来说，他们发现很难与其他人待在一起。现在，我办公室里有人戴着护目镜。墙上打开了一扇虚拟的门，不同种族、性别、体型、行为的人类走进房间，开始与患者互动，然后患者进行暴露练习。
So we have been using this technology and it works so well. You had a patient who was extremely afraid of spiders and you brought her in to your lab and you basically had these virtual reality goggles placed on her and you started, you know, running these spiders around the room that she could essentially interact with and you even recorded the session of you talking her through this session. I want to play you a little clip. So we can touch it? Why not? Why not?
所以我们一直在使用这项技术，而且效果非常好。你曾有一位极度害怕蜘蛛的患者，你把她带到你的实验室，基本上让她戴上了这些虚拟现实护目镜，然后你开始，你知道的，让这些蜘蛛在房间里爬来爬去，她基本上可以与之互动，你甚至录下了你陪同她完成这一疗程的对话。我想播放一小段剪辑。所以我们可以触摸它？为什么不呢？为什么不呢？
Why not? I touch it, you can touch it also. I'm just going to feel a board. Ooh, I'm under it. Swear if I'll warm her under it. That's good. That's very good. See if you can hold it like longer time. Because what are what are we doing? We are training your brain that this is safe. This is safe. This is safe Arash, what was happening in the session there? This is actually the part that she was trying to slide her hand under the spider How amazing the our brains perceive this that she started to even feel it She was like oh, it's for warmer it feels warmer here while she was sliding her hand under this thing. It's one thing to be okay with some virtual augmented spiders, but we want this to have real-life implications. So after that, we have a live tarantula. My lab is Stress Trauma and Anxiety Research Clinic, STARK, for the C, and this tarantula's name is Tony Stark.
为什么不呢？我触摸它，你也可以触摸它。我只是去摸一块木板。哦，我在它下面。我发誓如果我把它……哦，把它弄暖和了。很好。非常好。看看你能不能把它拿（放）更长的时间。因为我们在做什么？我们在训练你的大脑，这是安全的。这是安全的。这是安全的。阿拉什，当时那个治疗环节里发生了什么？这实际上是她试图把手滑到蜘蛛下方的那一部分。我们的大脑对这一点的感知是多么神奇啊，她甚至开始感觉到它。当她把手滑到这东西下面时，她说：“哦，它变暖了，这里感觉更暖和了。”能够接受一些虚拟或增强现实的蜘蛛是一回事，但我们希望这能在现实生活中产生影响。所以在那之后，我们有一只活的狼蛛。我的实验室是“压力、创伤与焦虑研究诊所”（STARK），取首字母缩写，这只狼蛛的名字叫托尼·斯塔克（Tony Stark）。
So we'll see how close they can get after the treatment to Tony Stark. And actually, this patient was able to go ultimately have Tony in her hand, which is a large rose hair tarantula. And interestingly, we have published this clinical trial. Everybody we treated with this technology for free of spiders. In less than one hour, one session treatment was able to touch Tony Stark or the tank containing Tony. And these are people who were standing 15 meters away from Tony before treatment. So you say that we might all want to practice
所以我们将看看治疗后他们能离托尼·斯塔克多近。实际上，这位患者最终能够把托尼拿在手上，那是一只大型的玫瑰毛狼蛛。有趣的是，我们已经发表了这项临床试验。我们用这项技术治疗的所有人都不再害怕蜘蛛。在不到一个小时的一次治疗中，他们就能够触摸托尼·斯塔克或装着托尼的饲养箱。而这些人在此之前在治疗前是站在距离托尼15米远的地方。所以你是说我们大家可能都想在日常生活中练习
a kind of exposure therapy as we go about our daily lives. How would this work, Arash? I always say the only way beyond fear is through fear. At the end of the day, exposure matters. We got to throw ourselves in it. Of course, we want to do it the way that we succeed. So gradually, one step at a time, and I recommend people go to the minimum level I can do. Let's say I am afraid of grocery shopping because of my anxieties. Just go to a grocery store which is smaller, which you're most comfortable, at a time that there may be even two people at the store.
某种暴露疗法。阿拉什，这该如何运作？我总是说，超越恐惧的唯一方法就是穿过恐惧。归根结底，暴露才是最重要的。我们必须把自己投身其中。当然，我们希望以能够成功的方式去做。因此要循序渐进，一次迈出一小步，我建议人们从我能做到的最低级别开始。比方说，由于我的焦虑，我很害怕去杂货店买东西。那就去一个更小、让你最感到舒适的杂货店，挑一个店里可能只有两三个人的时间去。
Just go there, stay there. What matters most is stay with that scary situation, whether it's the date, whether it's the grocery store. Stay with that little tiny bit. Keep repeating and repeating and repeating until I master that stage. Now I have a sense of autonomy. I've learned my own limits. I've learned how my brain and my body responds to this.
去那里，待在那里。最重要的是待在那个可怕的情境中，无论是约会还是去杂货店。就待在那一点点的不适中。不断地、不断地、不断地重复，直到我掌握了那个阶段。现在我有了自主感。我了解了自己的极限。我了解了我的大脑和身体对此是如何反应的。
Then go to the next level, then go to the next level, then go to the next level. And I've seen a lot of good responses from people who do this. I understand that you once got the opportunity to unlearn a fear during a visit to the Grand Canyon. Tell me what happened, Arash. Yeah, so this happened. I still laugh every time I think about it. Many years ago, I was doing my residency and I had a week of vacation I had to use in December.
然后进入下一个级别，再进入下一个级别，再进入下一个级别。我从这样做的人身上看到了很多好的反馈。我听说你曾有机会在游览大峡谷时消解了一种恐惧。告诉我发生了什么，阿拉什。是的，事情是这样的。每次我想起它，我还是会笑。很多年前，我在做住院医师实习，在12月我有一周必须休完的年假。
One of my friends who was very adventurous tells me that, hey, go to Grand Canyon, there's this mule ride down the bottom of the canyon, it's beautiful. And I was so naive, I didn't think for a second that I'm afraid of heights. So I signed up for this thing. I go there six a.m. in the morning in December very cold Everybody's wearing several layers
我的一位非常喜欢冒险的朋友告诉我，嘿，去大峡谷吧，那里有骑骡子下峡谷底部的项目，风景非常美。我是如此的天真，以至于我甚至没有一秒钟想到我有恐高症。所以我报名了这个项目。我在12月的早晨六点钟到达那里，天气非常冷，每个人都穿着好几层衣服。
Sitting on this huge mules and that was the first time I saw What Grand Canyon is you look down and you see the bottom? It was terrifying and we were told listen if you're afraid you can leave now But you have to leave now. When we start moving, you cannot back off. And I'm like thinking, should I stop? Should I not? Should I looking around, seeing all these kids and older people?
坐在这些巨大的骡子上，那是第一次我看到了大峡谷是什么样子的。你往下看，能看到谷底。这太吓人了，我们被告知：听着，如果你害怕，你现在可以离开。但你必须现在离开。当我们开始移动时，你就不能退缩了。我心里想：我应该停下来吗？我不该停下来吗？我环顾四周，看到所有这些小孩和老人都觉得很舒服？
Are they comfortable? Having fun? I was embarrassed. I'm like, okay, we'll do it. And these mules, they tend to walk on the edge of the canyon. And it was icy and slippery, sometimes they slipped. And when they make you, and the trails are narrow, and when they make you turn, you just see the bottom of the canyon. Your mules head is off the canyon, basically.
他们在玩得很开心？我很尴尬。我想，好吧，我们干吧。而这些骡子，它们往往沿着峡谷边缘行走。当时路面结冰而且很滑，有时它们会滑倒。当它们让你……而且小路很窄，当你拐弯时，你只能看到峡谷底部。基本上，你的骡子的头都已经悬在峡谷外面了。
So it was very terrifying for me. But knowing what are the principles of this exposure, I tried to basically do as much as I could, looking at others, getting so, seeing other people are having fun, remembering the fact they told us that they were running this business for 100 years and nobody has been injured or died,
所以我当时非常害怕。但了解了这种暴露疗法的原理后，我试着尽我所能去做：看着别人，变得……看到别人玩得很开心，记住他们告诉我们的事实——他们经营这个业务已经100年了，没有人受伤或死亡，
no mule has been killed. So basically, utilizing all my cognitive and not cognitive resources, we went down to the canyon and the next day we come back up. And that basically, not that I recommend this as a way of overcoming your fears, but that's was it for me. And I overcame my fear of heights. Actually, a couple of weeks ago I was back in Grand Canyon.
没有一头骡子丧生。所以基本上，利用了我所有的认知和非认知资源，我们下到了峡谷底部，第二天我们又爬了上来。这基本上——倒不是我建议把它作为克服恐惧的方法，但对我来说就是这样。我克服了恐高症。实际上，几周前我又回到了大峡谷。
I stood on the edge of that cliff, of course in a safe way. I felt the tingling in my knees, but I could do it. And another amazing experience that came out of this, besides the overcoming my fear of heights, was for the next few days, I realized I'm not experiencing my usual anxieties of daily life. And I started thinking about what is the source? I mean, one theory I came up with was that maybe we need some occasional experiences of real fear to exercise the fear system in a normal way.
我站在那处悬崖的边缘，当然是用安全的方式。我感到了膝盖发麻，但我能做到。而除此之外另一个令人惊叹的体验，除了克服恐高症之外，就是在接下来的几天里，我意识到我没有经历日常生活中那种通常的焦虑。我开始思考根源是什么？我的一个理论是，也许我们需要一些真实恐惧的偶尔体验，以正常的方式来锻炼恐惧系统。
The same way we exercise our bodies to be healthy because our lives are so sedentary these days. The other thing I realized was that when we experienced such real fears, because at that moment I'm standing on the edge of that cliff on that mule, what is my fear? My fear is if I fall, I'm dead. So now I'm facing a real fear. Now, in compared to this fear, how much does it matter? The things that are going on at work or the paper that got rejected or this Disagreement that I've lived with this other person basically these kind of fears put other anxieties in context
就像我们为了保持健康而锻炼身体一样，因为如今我们的生活太缺乏运动了。我意识到的另一件事是，当我们经历这种真实的恐惧时——因为在那一刻，我骑在骡子上站在悬崖边缘，我的恐惧是什么？我的恐惧是如果我掉下去，我就死定了。所以我现在面临的是一种真实的恐惧。相比之下，这些恐惧算得了什么？工作上发生的事情、被拒稿的论文，或者我和另一个人之间的意见不合——基本上，这些种类的恐惧让其他焦虑有了背景。
Yeah, because the other fear started look trivial at this point compared to actually plunging to your death You know 2,000 feet in the Grand Canyon Absolutely, and that's why a lot of people I mean we did talk a lot about the trauma And let's say first first responders, police, firefighters, veterans, but the other side of it is that people who have seen the real dangerous situations, who have experienced what really matters, a lot of them have grown to the point that they find other anxieties that bother the rest of us meaningless. We've talked about different ways
是的，因为与实际上在大峡谷2000英尺高空坠落身亡相比，此时其他的恐惧看起来都微不足道了。完全是这样，这就是为什么很多人——我的意思是，我们确实讨论了很多关于创伤的内容，比方说第一响应者、警察、消防员、退伍军人，但另一方面是，那些见过真正危险情况、经历过真正重要事情的人，他们中的许多人已经成长到这样一种地步：他们发现困扰我们其余人的其他焦虑毫无意义。我们已经讨论了不同的方法
to get our fears under control, but it's also possible for us to change, in some ways, what's on the other side of the equation. When we're afraid of something, instead of reducing our fear, we can increase how much we care about the thing that our fears are holding us back from. In some cases, that bigger thing
来控制我们的恐惧，但我们也有可能在某种程度上改变方程式的另一端。当我们害怕某事时，我们不仅可以减少恐惧，还可以增加我们对那些阻碍我们的事物所倾注的关切。在某些情况下，那个更宏大的事物
might be a sense of duty or patriotism. So when Western countries offered to airlift Ukrainian president Volodymyr Zelensky to safety after Russia invaded Ukraine in February 2022, he said, I need ammunition, not a ride. Can you talk about this idea, Arash, that the things we care about deeply can be a bulwark against our fears. And that's one amazing thing about us humans, that we are capable of overcoming
可能是一种责任感或爱国主义。因此，在2022年2月俄罗斯入侵乌克兰后，当西方国家提出用飞机将乌克兰总统弗拉基米尔·泽连斯基空运至安全地带时，他说：“我需要的是弹药，而不是顺风车。”阿拉什，你能谈谈这个观点吗：我们深切关怀的事物可以成为抵御恐惧的堡垒。这也是我们人类的一大神奇之处，我们有能力克服
a lot of terrifying situations that we even did not know we were capable of. What I found in my career is that the meaning we create for our experiences transcends a lot of our fears and can help us basically protect us against fear. So sometimes the thing that is bigger than our fear is I love for another person.
许多甚至连我们自己都不知道自己有能力应对的恐怖情境。我在职业生涯中发现，我们为自己的经历赋予的意义，超越了许多恐惧，并能从根本上帮助我们抵御恐惧。所以有时比我们的恐惧更伟大的事物，是我们对另一个人的爱。
When you were training as a doctor, you once helped a family who had been brought into the emergency room. Paint me a picture of what happened to Rush. So I was in the emergency room and there was a car accident. There's a mom on a stretcher with a very pale face and there's a dad and a couple of kids, probably five, six years old. And I remember this woman's son was next to this stretcher terrified, crying, worried about his mom.
当你作为医生接受培训时，你曾帮助过一个被送到急诊室的家庭。阿拉什，给我描绘一下当时发生了什么。当时我在急诊室，发生了一起车祸。担架上躺着一位母亲，脸色非常苍白，旁边是一位父亲和几个孩子，大概五、六岁大。我记得这位女性的儿子就挨着担架，吓得要死，一直在哭，很担心他的妈妈。
And mom was basically so calmly, such a soothing way saying, it's okay, I'm alright, nothing bad has happened, it's okay. And then we unwrap her arm which was wrapped in a sheet or towel, I don't exactly remember, and I saw the worst injury crushed bones on her arm. I was just amazed by it. This is crushing pain. And she knows she has a high chance of losing this arm. But for her, the priority is to make sure her child is OK
而母亲基本上非常平静、以一种极其抚慰人心的方式说：“没事的，我很好，没有什么坏事发生，没事的。”然后我们解开了她手臂上的包裹——她的手臂裹着床单或毛巾，我记不太清了，我看到了最可怕的伤势：手臂上粉碎性骨折。我当时简直惊呆了。这是剧烈的疼痛。她知道自己有很大几率失去这条手臂。但对她而言，首要任务是确保她的孩子没事，
and not terrified and not hurting. And this was one of the most amazing examples of selflessness and bravery I've seen. Aarash Javanbhakt is the director of the Stress, Trauma and Anxiety Research Clinic at Wayne State University School of Medicine. He's the author of Afraid, Understanding the Purpose of Fear and Harnessing the Power of Anxiety. Arash, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me on Shankar.
而且没有受到惊吓，没有受伤。这是我见过的最令人惊叹的无私和勇敢的例子之一。阿拉什·贾万巴赫特是韦恩州立大学医学院压力、创伤与焦虑研究诊所的主任。他著有《害怕：理解恐惧的目的并驾驭焦虑的力量》。阿拉什，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你邀请我来，尚卡尔。
Do you have questions for Arash Javanbhakt? What kind of fears have you faced in your own life? If you'd be willing to share a personal story and the strategies you've used to combat your fears with the hidden brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and send it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. 60 seconds is plenty. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line fear. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
你对阿拉什·贾万巴赫特有什么问题吗？你在自己的生活中面对过什么样的恐惧？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享一段个人故事以及你用来对抗恐惧的策略，请在手机上录制一段语音便签，并发送给我们，邮箱是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。60秒就足够了。再次重复那个电子邮箱地址是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。请使用“fear”（恐惧）作为邮件主题。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。
Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristin Wong, Laura Quirelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Hidden Brain listener Joy Smith. Not long ago, Joy noticed that multiple episodes of our show had been marked as explicit in Apple Podcasts. We realize that this era might make some listeners reluctant to play those episodes. Everything is marked correctly now. Thank you Joy for spotting the problem and sending us a note about it. If you liked today's show, please share it with one or two people in your life. Word-of-mouth
我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲-保尔（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristin Wong）、劳拉·奎雷尔（Laura Quirelle）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们这周的无名英雄是《隐藏的大脑》听众乔伊·史密斯（Joy Smith）。不久前，乔伊注意到我们节目的多个单集在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）中被标记为“带有一儿不宜内容”。我们意识到，这个标记可能会让一些听众不太愿意播放这些单集。现在所有内容都已正确标记。感谢乔伊发现问题并给我们发了便签。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请把它分享给你生活中的一到两个人。口口相传
recommendations are the best way to help us connect more listeners to the ideas we explore on Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant, see you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
推荐是帮助我们将更多听众与我们在《隐藏的大脑》中探讨的想法联系起来的最佳方式。我是尚卡尔·韦达南塔（Shankar Vedantam），我们回头见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。